that his wife was [__] her son's
friend okay
now
I normally would not talk about this
but for some reason these put that [__]
on the internet Chris Roth took aim at
Will Smith over the weekend during his
live Netflix comedy special selective
outrage referencing the cheating rumors
that surrounded will and his wife Jada
Pinkett Smith in 2020. I got into an
entanglement with
August that's what I said an
entanglement yes
one year after will slapped him at the
Oscars
she hurt him way more than he hurt me
okay and who's he hit me now August
Alsina the singer and reality star who
had an entanglement with Will's wife is
shutting down the reports that he's
watched the special I am rooted for Will
Smith my whole life I root for this okay
and now I watch emancipation just to see
him get whooped
in response to reports that August
watched Chris's stand-up routine and
thought it was funny the singer's rep
tells E.T This Is A Lie Mr Alcina has
not seen Chris Rock special at all as
he's been busy on tour
I've got smacked in the [__] Oscars
by this
the performance marked the first time
the comedian publicly addressed will
slapping him at the 94th annual Academy
Awards
the people I didn't hurt it still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears
I was just glad to see after what
happened and all the trauma and stuff
that he emerged stronger I'm glad he's
getting a chance to be seen and
appreciated as part of his set Chris
addressed the rumors of an affair
between August and Jada and the couple's
emotional chat about it on red table
talk Chris said will was practicing
selective outrage when he hit him
really knows knows I had nothing to do
with that I didn't have any
entanglements it was a relationship
absolutely I was in a lot of pain and I
was very broken we all been cheated on
everybody in him been cheated on none of
us have ever
on television
would you do that
a source previously told ET that Will
and Jada have been on a journey of
healing over the last year putting a lot
of effort into their relationship and
are closer than ever Jade and I have you
know we weathered some storms and that
that's really uh for me the the only way
that you can get to the other sides as
for Chris after the Comedy Special A
source told E.T he said everything he
wanted to say and is ready to move on
[Music]
thank you